est-ce qu'on avait un auditeur proposé à
junior kourou et danic et sa grand-mère
et
la face
ouest et non sa taille
l'extraordinaire vraiment là pour
regarder regarder ouais josé kelly
bonjour c'est romain
bonjour romain je me présente romain ce
n'est pas une blague je suis julien
courbet nous sommes en direct sur la
roma mère et ma grand mère ça fait quand
même beaucoup ma grand-mère
malheureusement elle est décédée
je la respecte trop pour ces gens dont
vous me demander d'aller nique et ma
mère et ma grand mère si je devais faire
tout ce que les gens me propose de faire
depuis qu'on a lancé cette émission
serait terré puisque la dernière fois
qu'est ce qu'on m'avait dit d'aller
faire bas d'aller pratiquer la sodomie
tu t'en es bien sorti ouais très fort
parce que je me dis qu'est ma mère
il m'a dit me dit l'enfant vieux est
incroyable ça restera vraiment
et ça c'est ma direct c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas mal de mecs maintenant qui
de temps en temps il ya longtemps
maintenant en fait quand il ya un gars
on sait pas ce qu'il faut juste qu'on
mette lampant
l'enfance et non tu sais quand
l'ambiance retour balance un photomaton
le truc c'est que souvent quand les gens
savent pas quoi dire les insulte voilà
c'est une façon de se dérober est ce
qu'on a vu julien courbet recevoir un
appel d'un certain benjamin 6 pour se
plaindre des audiences du 6 à 7 d'un
certain bernard
[Applaudissements]
saurait vraie paix est ce qu on a vu ça
lâche oblige je te la mettrait à chaque
fois que tu viendras bon hockey balle à
la vitre
oui je prends la vie dans le bas
de la veille à suivre kamal se fera mais
ça c'était incroyable ce qu'on a vu
julien combes et jouer les cascadeurs
dans la série plus belle la vie trop mis
sept sénateurs la vie et rend la peau du
cou mais si je reste je le rappelle la
ville et je le rappelle pour rappel le
conseil des ministres de bain se jouer
en fait de boire ce métier de quiévrain
les parents d'une anonyme il
représentait une personne connue et donc
que julien était la personne connue est
en fait il était censé être un mec iv
quad plaindre et bonbons des jeunes sur
la terrasse en face des paroles je le
redis je reviens je vais la cuisine
chercher un truc sûrement pour me faire
briefer et quand je reviens au lieu de
partir sur la droite part sur la gauche
et une baie vitrée je crois que rien et
je me prends la vie me traynard je me
réjouis très mal
mais non parce que en fait julien enfin
ça me rassure parce qu'il n'y a pas que
pour ma bd même ces concepts lui ces
peines
est ce que vous vous demandez juste un
petit truc machin magueur aller qu'avec
les yeux
comme ça on vous prendra
au
sérieux et c'est donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demain j'ai quand même continué mon
métier
je te jure horizons mais juliette c'est
que peut la revoir
voilà la jeune fille parle et quand il
arrive qu'on s'y attend pas mais non ait
un tel coût comme des 110
que sont na pas le genre mais telle est
la même mais le bas
[Musique]
je me suis fait super mal c'est sûr je
suis même un peu cassé le nez norway
coup de fil après pour savoir comment
j'allais
c'est à l'époque qui pensaient qu'à
prendre de l'oseille jobs
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire rien du tout c'est pas ça
va être ça paie ses thèmes et encore
c'était pas mal ben voilà c'est pas mal
mais ça sonne faux c'est la faulx mais
pas mal faut mais pas prenez pas de
marche en émission je les fais
d'ailleurs l'émission pour toi maintien
de la paix un pilote tu vas adorer
manono et vous deviez garder des enfants
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai était
diffusé pourquoi l'émission qui marche
ou en production
du court la sarabande vendus dans 22
pays non valeo les seuils labadie jay
bruce et moi
[Rires]
c'est très bien oui génial ellison
de touche mais bien sûr ça c'est tout
pour lui non mais oui on vit
quand même traité d'abruti
[Rires]
sur tout va bien j'entends barberis et
c'est l'intérêt de la journée mais c'est
vrai qu'à vous deux vous avez tous les
sens
c'est vrai
ça commence à ressembler à un être
humain
il est 19h30 run petite respiration la
fente de gilles
l'été la mobilité
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est en toi et moi
je vais le tuer le père je vais en faire
un cadre et je vais la mettre sur ma
table de nuit
et je vous enverrai la photo de malassan
est dommage j'aurais eu quatre sur ma
table de nuit et vous verrez un ouais
t'as 2010 qui chante we do non parce que
je vous vois déjà qu est ce qu a
maintenant comment ils décorer votre
chambre mais je crois que tu crois que
c'est moi qui vais décorer ma femme il
ya juste un lycée tout pour dormir non
quoi saluer décorateur
pas besoin de ça mais si à l'écran qui
se lèvent de vente
[Musique]
[Rires]
il
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chapeau mais non tirées ouais c'est vrai
que la pia et à la télé dans la piscine
chez vous pas
n'avait pas tarder à les travailler
aquaboulevard
beaucoup des piscines des bras des
tombeaux borges est ce qu
est ce qu on avait tu dois qu'on va
avoir du mal à garder son sérieux pose
une perruque mal mise sur le crâne de
son amant oui oui oui c'est dans les
sept péchés cas passer le juste soin et
le monsieur il avait une perruque très
mal placé il a posé comme ça il est en
plateau et pour lui dit c'est à vous il
part dans le mauvais sens c'est
peut-être comme ça donc l'assistant le
routier d'un coup sec du coup ça peut
être
et lui il arrive comme ça
c'est comme ça
c'était bien placé au nab elle est
incroyable il était juste posé il avait
passé les dons continuent à secouer la
regarder si la sécurité sociale au moins
va rembourser cet homme est
désespérée mais je suis très perplexe
parce que j'en ai pas à comprendre
comment monsieur souvent une lettre qui
ne l'est pas tester donc pas son nom il
prend le train pour à leur endroit où il
était attendu elle existe c'est pas de
la fiction c'est vrai ça c'est du coup
je suis bien très très dur je n'ai pas
destiné non les 8 est destinée la lettre
dont lui reproche dans le deuxième
courrier de la sécurité sociale quand il
a voulu se faire en lui dit on lui dit
de choses qu'il aurait eue se renseigner
il s'est renseigné deux fois ensuite que
le courrier normal
mais dès que besoin
[Musique]
nicolas et julien tu sais que je fous
rires julia a gardé les mêmes équipes on
embrasse yann jolivet away hervé qu'on a
vu arriver sur le piolet d'or c'est un
amour à fait je vois toujours dehors là
c'est extraordinaire vingt deux ans
maintenant on met ensemble à la radio et
bernard sabbah également bien sûr
bernard sabatte
car il travaille quinze jours par
semaine on l'appelle comme ça est ce
qu'on a vu julien combat il faire une
petite publicité pour des fenêtres en
tunisie pour la marque hope tard et
fenêtres
[Rires]
c'est gratuit est ce qu'on a vu julien
courbet exciter la foule avec un strip
tease pas très catholique oui
[Musique]
ici à londres et dans l'émission enfin
te voilà sur comédie plus sains que
c'est que cette émission est ce que ces
cessions est afin s'est plaint jeudi
lacombe est surexcité alors déguisé en
curé quoi s'éclater indiqué produisent
jamais vu c'est un drame et jauzion
abbas et vous a manqué un problème
regardez j'ai peur qu'ils aient un
problème aussi je portais un problème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça fait tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on commence à mettre bout à bout
toutes les fois où je me suis mis à poil
sur un plateau en cours à savoir un
petit documentaire
commence à avoir des petites choses
j'haïs il était bien de l'image vrai
c'est vrai ce qu'on a vu julien combes
et scrat et le tout plus discrètement
sur un plateau télé oui n'ont pas vu
mais presque on a failli c'était dans la
grande barre cas lorsque laurent baffie
est il possible de faire des choses un
petit peu bizarre ça c'est un grand
moment ci regarde ma fille qui va
répondre à l'interview ta place je
devrais dire tout ce que te dit laurent
gbagbo
n'aurait il faut que je répète ce que tu
dis pas que tu fasses que papa tu
évoques parce que les me demande de m
j'ai déjà pris de la drogue avant une
émission non mais j'en ai vendu non mais
j'en ai vendu
[Applaudissements]
il a complété par
contre aucune attention à elle ne
figurait sur m6 aussi en simultané